16-year old Warren cave was taken into
custody 16 year-old boy will be tried as
an adult
Warren who is sentenced to life in
prison for murdering his neighbor at 16
years old and he has now spent 19 years
of that sentence you first meet Warren
as this young shy strange little kid and
now he's a much more hardened man Warren
is a very very complicated character he
adopted some beliefs that were not his
own and he became someone other than the
person that his family knew him to be
this is the only family you got papi
Parnell is an investigative journalist
who helped to send Warren Cave to prison
and it's a very uncomfortable position
for her to be in she's believing maybe
she was wrong and maybe Warren was
innocent so she is possibly the one and
only person that will try to make truth
reach the surface you are stepping in
something you've got no business being
around everybody's lives stopped in one
way or the other the night of that
murder and they're existing as the
walking wounded you left us oh and you
took everything from being Warren you
still 19 years of my life
19 years Melanie is dying of cancer and
she feels helpless that she can't help
her son and she only so much time if you
live there is this ticking clock to get
out and spend the last moments with her
Melanie is a mother who will not stop
until she sees justice for her son
there's not enough evidence to
constitute a new trial motion denied
my son is innocent only believes just
sons guilty and doesn't forgive him
Warren has such an interesting
relationship with his father who
testified against him stop talking to
that woman you leave it or I can make
your life miserable in here high five
couch era Warren K makes you hate him he
makes you love him and you're possibly
left wondering what side of the fence is
this guy playing
the whole of my mother dialogue